hi there steve kaufman here i want to
talk about vocabulary primarily
and vocabulary learning using this
term interleaving which was a term that
i introduced
in my previous video which is based on
recent research into how we learn and
which says that
rather than deliberate focused
learning of something
we're better off to
learn two or three things and go back to
them and
basically meander around and stagger and
intersperse or interleave our learning
that
those people who study very deliberately
in blocks in massive blocks may do
better in the short term but in the long
term they retain less
than people who
do different tasks or work on different
skills
forget come back do it again and so
forth
apparently one of the
uh and i suggest that you can google the
term interleave l-e-a-v-e interleaved
and find a fair amount of uh
articles on it and some people in the
comments to my previous video said you
know this is just a new term for
something that's been known
a long time
but i wanted to talk a little bit about
vocabulary
and and talk about some of the comments
that the previous video
seemed to elicit one person said you
know bruce lee said that i don't fear
the person who has practiced ten
thousand kicks once i hear the person
who has practiced one kick ten thousand
times
yeah if your objective was to learn one
kick
then that's a good strategy
however in language learning we don't
need to learn one kick or one word we
need to learn
an awful lot of words we need to learn
tens of thousands of words eventually if
we want to achieve fluency we need to
learn to recognize them eventually to
get a sense of how they're used together
with other words eventually we want to
learn to use them ourselves
it's a gradual
process
and it covers lots of words and phrases
that are you know made up of these words
so it's not a matter of learning one
kick so i think that's not a relevant uh
comparison at all
another person
perhaps on that video or on another
video was commenting on the number of
words that i seem to have learned
during my 90 day korean challenge and if
i look at my statistics during those 90
days i added 10 000 words to my known
words total
and i saved
9820 links that means to say i saved
9820 words and phrases
converted them from blue into yellow
um
i read 78 000 words during that period
and i listened to all of that at least
once usually many many times
and i spoke for 13 hours so those are
the statistics now
10 000 new known words
one thing about words the way we count
them at link it's very important to
realize that
every change every inflection in the
word is counted as a separate word i
prefer that because
if i learn
the word a particular word in this tense
or in this case if it's a noun and i see
it again
a i might have forgotten that i ever
looked it up
so or you know the previous form of it
so the idea of saving that word again in
a different form
strengthens my ability to
identify the meaning the scope of that
word and as i see the word in different
forms and i save them
that helps me get a sense of the
overall way that word is used so uh
obviously you can't compare that to a
number based on word families but that's
how we count them so 10 000 words and
close to 10 000 words saved now of the
9820 words that i say words and phrases
of course i don't know them all if i go
through the list in my vocabulary
section that link
i'll find that the most frequent words
these are four star words at link i'll
know most of them 70 or 80
because they've appeared frequently
enough i've seen them in different
contexts i know them even without
studying them in flashcards i know them
the three star words i know well it's
still pretty close those
two most frequent groups i'm going to be
in the 70 that was in my experience
once you get down to the two star words
and the one star words it falls 50 40
30. so i really don't know exactly of
those 9 800
links that i saved how many
i actually know
but i think it's close to half so
therefore in the three month period i
learned i added to my vocabulary based
on how we counted link
fifteen thousand words five thousand
words a month
uh
why for example when i say the known
words is ten thousand because i'll if i
see a word that's another form of a word
that i have already saved i won't save
it it'll be known
uh if i see a word that seems similar to
a word that i have already saved from
the context i know what it means i i
don't save it
so uh in fact we end up i end up picking
up more words in this sort of incidental
way perhaps twice as many words are
learned incidentally than through
deliberately saving them at link
but in any case
5 000 words a month
i think that if i were to have
deliberately studied lists of words or
done it through anki which is a system
of flash card
study there is no way that i could have
learned that many words that i could
have increased my vocabulary by that
many words
what did i do i basically practiced
interleaving i just went from episode to
episode in this kim yong-ha's
podcast
i read some newspapers i also reviewed
some easy content
all the while coming across these words
when i see
the yellow words if i don't remember i
quickly just look at it and i it's
refreshed so i'm in a sense testing
myself i'm reading
i'm listening i'm forcing myself to
understand
i'm testing myself
but i'm not looking to master anything
i'm just looking to get this to flow
over me and to reappear words reappear
in different contexts so to that extent
i think an interleaving approach such as
i've just described
to um
vocabulary acquisition delivers
dramatically better results than more
traditional methods
um the same is true just uh to divert a
little bit as a diversion with lan with
grammar some people came on and said you
know the thing to do is to have a very
limited vocabulary and really focus on
the
basics of grammar
i personally think that's very hard to
do very few people can do that i can
focus on the grammar as i did in the
past for say german cases
try to learn it try to memorize it
repeat it to myself it doesn't stick
however if i learn lots of words through
this interleaving process
say phrases see the language in action
occasionally review the grammar rules
again interleaving it go back to reading
and listening gradually it starts to
stick so in both cases and i think to
some extent
grammar learning is related to
vocabulary learning to the extent that
every word in its different
form and the different endings that it
has
uh
represents
a form of
the grammar
put together in phrases they represent
the patterns of the language and the
more we are exposed to these patterns in
different uh contexts
the more we we become used to them and
that ultimately that's a better way
of getting a sense of the grammar
than deliberately studying the grammar
and we can go a long way
in listening and reading without having
the grammar nailed down
i mean the ukrainian i'm doing now is
not a good example because the grammar
is so similar to russian
but even when i did
you know romanian or other languages
occasionally refer to the grammar which
is quite different from say italian but
i don't need to have it all nailed down
i don't need to know
the cases or or any number of different
things the funny futures that they have
or in iranian in order to
be able to understand and as long as i
can understand i can continue
interleaving continue exposing myself to
the language
uh so
to summarize again i think
for vocabulary acquisition and by
implication for grammar acquisition
uh interleaving just absorbing it
uh
gradually letting it settle in there
different settlements
is the way to go in my opinion and i'm
sure i'll have people with different
perspectives on this and i look forward
to your comments